ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi, and welcome
to another Android Developer
Lab+ for the 13th of
December, 2012.
It is actually our final ADL+
for the year, so I hope you're
excited because we're talking
about a new API that we've
recently launched.
And let me first introduce
our special guest.
Welcome, Paul Saxman.
Paul, why don't you introduce
yourself?
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
My name is Paul Saxman.
And I'm a developer advocate
on the Google Maps team.
And so I will be working more
on the Android APIs and some
of our other API that we
recently announced that I
won't talk about but we will be
talking about in the next
couple of weeks.
And yeah, so we're really
excited to be here and to talk
a little more about what's going
on in the Android Map.
Or is it the Google
Maps Android API?
ANKUR KOTWAL: v2.
PAUL SAXMAN: v2.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, it's really
good to have you.
So thank you for joining
us today.
And we have our usual regulator,
Tony Chan.
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
Hello, everyone.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Joining us from
Hong Kong, as usual.
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
And I'm joining you from
Mountain View,
California this week.
And yeah, we're just waiting
to get started.
So that being said, let's get
started with the presentation.
Just sharing my slides,
and here we are.
So as usual, first we'll start
off with what's been happening
recently in terms of news.
We launched an Android
Developer Survey very recently.
And basically we're asking
Android developers to give us
feedback on a whole
range of topics.
It takes probably anywhere
between 5 and 15 minutes,
depending on how long
you spend on it.
But it's really valuable
information to us.
And we want to hear what your
experience is like.
So please do let us know.
The survey is closing
fairly soon.
And yeah, it helps
us prioritize the
work that we do.
It helps us go to the
engineering team and tell us
that these are the important
things that the developers are
asking for.
And so more data points is
always a good thing.
In other news, we've recently
launched Google Play
Services version 2.
So if you remember back to
about two months ago, we
launched version 1, which had
the OAuth 2.0 component as
well as the Google+ API.
Well, now we have version 2.
And it includes the Google Maps
Android API version 2 as
well, which explains
why Paul is here.
So there's tons of great
things about it.
For starters, we get
vector-based maps, so we're
able to retain graphical
fidelity regardless of what
zoom level you're at.
We have beautiful 3D camera
control now, so not just your
zoom and rotate but
tilt as well.
And you'll get 3D buildings
popping up in cities that
support them.
It includes support for Indoor
Maps and of course everything
that developers have been asking
for for a while, which
is Map Fragments.
Hopefully we're not going to see
any questions now saying
when can we use Maps on tablets,
because they're
finally here.
Google Play Services version
2 also included a
Photo Sphere API.
So Photo Sphere is a new feature
on Android 4.2, which
basically allows you to capture
a 360-degree panorama.
They're really beautiful.
There's some great ones up
there on Google+, so go
hunting for them.
They're wroth looking at.
And so obviously we have some
APIs around that too.
And next up is In-App Billing.
So one of the things the
developers have been asking
for with In-App Billing is
being able to have a
synchronous way of doing it.
So in the past with In-App
Billing version 1 and 2, what
would happen is you send off a
purchase request, and it would
get back to you at
some point later.
Whereas now as soon as you ask
for it you'll get a response.
So you'll basically wait
for a response.
So this really simplifies
coding around the API.
It makes it a lot more
reliable as well.
And there's a ton of new
functionality there as well,
including local caching and
something, again, developers
have been asking for, which
is being able to query for
product info.
So now with this API you can
actually query at runtime to
say what are the In-App
purchases available, what are
their prices, and what are
their description.
So you no longer need to hard
code those prices in your
applications, which is just
great news both for developers
but also for users.
So the thing that's missing in
In-App Billing version 3 at
the moment is subscription, but
that's coming very soon.
And it's we basically expect
developers to start using
version 3 as soon as possible
because it really is great.
So with that being said, I'm now
going to hand it over to
Tony to talk to us about
the Maps API.
So Tony.
TONY CHAN: Yeah, thanks.
So let's get started.
So before we get into the
details, let me give a brief
introduction on how to get
started to incorporate the new
Maps API into your
Android apps.
So the first thing you need to
have is, of course, installing
in the Google Play Services is
including part of the Android
SDK Manager.
So if you go to Eclipse and
launch the SDK Manager, you
will see a new version of
Google Play Services,
which is version 2.
And just install it.
That's the first step.
Next slide.
The next thing you need to have
is, of course, just like
the first version, you need to
have a Google Maps API key.
So one thing which is really
important is the existing key
you have if you already have an
application using the Maps
view version 1, one thing
important is that the key for
version 1 is not going to work
with the version 2 API.
So you do need to generate a
new Maps API key to use the
new version.
Another thing about the API key
is it's generated in the
Google API Console.
So pay attention.
That's not the Google Play
Developer Console.
So I actually include a
screenshot of what the Google
API Console looks like.
You can go to this Console
by going to
code.google.com/apis/console.
So one thing you will notice now
under the All Services, if
you already have a Google
project, you will see the
Google Maps API version 2
services available now.
You can click into that
to generate new keys.
Next slide.
So about the Maps API key, you
need two things to generate
the Maps API key.
The key itself is a
40-character key.
But in order to generate a key
you need to have two things.
One is your apps certificate's
SHA1 fingerprint.
And the next thing is
the package name.
So how to get the SHA1
fingerprint.
You can use the keytool
command line.
I have included the
command line here.
But one thing you need to pay
attention to is you need to
use the -v verbose attribute so
that it will show the SHA1
fingerprint.
So one thing is if you don't
include it the -v parameter,
by default the fingerprint shown
on the result is going
to be MD5 fingerprint, which
looks almost exactly like the
SHA1 fingerprint.
So we had some developers try to
run the keytools, and then
they said they couldn't generate
the key because it's
the wrong fingerprint.
In this case, we need the SHA1
fingerprint itself, MD5-1.
Another best practice I want
to share with you is it's a
good practice to use a different
certificate to sign
each application.
So in this case you will use
your application's certificate
to get the SHA1 fingerprint.
And then we append the package
name after colon.
And you will generate the
right Maps API key.
Next slide.
So another thing you need to
make sure to include in your
project, especially if you
want to target anything
earlier than API 11.
So in most cases I
think the Support
Library is really important.
So the new Maps API also
backports to the Support
Library, and so you need
to install the
latest Support Library.
Instead of using the Map
Fragment, if you use the
Support Library use support
Map Fragment.
Next slide.
So now let's talk about how
after you generate the Maps
API key how to include that
in your application.
So if you go to your
AndroidManifest.xml, you need
to add a metadata tag with the
name com.google android.maps
v2 API key.
And then you paste your newly
generated API key
to the value attribute.
You also need to create a custom
permission to include
that in your Android Manifest.
The permission name is
your package name dot
permission.maps_receive.
So I already include all the
details in the slide.
So that's a special custom
permission you need.
You also need some other
permissions.
Next slides.
So here are a couple of
permission that you most
likely will need.
The first one is the internet
connection.
So we need to download
the map tiles from
the Google Maps server.
You also need to include the
right external storage
permission to take advantage
of the caching of Maps.
Another Google Services
permissions.
That's a permission we need to
access all the Google web
based services.
There are a couple optional but
most likely very useful
for most of the Maps application
is you probably
need access to course location
and find location if you plan
to get access to the user
current location.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So I just want
to emphasize the point here
that Tony made.
The access course and find
location are truly optional.
Don't just blindly include them
just because you're using
the Library.
Because often you'll have a map
in your app and you're not
actually using the
user's location.
I've written many apps using
this new API where I didn't
need these permissions.
So it's really important
that people don't just
blindly copy and paste.
We've had a previous
presentation on abusing
permissions.
So yeah, don't be overzealous
with them.
TONY CHAN: Yeah,
thanks, Ankur.
So the next thing you need to
include in the manifest is to
include the feature OpenGL
ES version 2.
As Ankur mentioned earlier,
the new Maps are using
vector-based maps, and that's
actually a requirement to have
OpenGL ES version 2.
So I'm sure you guys will enjoy
trying out the new API.
So one small favor we need to
ask you guys to include is
attribution requirement in order
to use the new Maps API.
So you can add that as a
separate action item or as
part of your original or your
own About action item in your
application.
We make it even easier
for you.
So there is API core from Google
Play Services to get
the open source software
licensing code.
So you just need to grab that
text from that method and just
include that in your About
Us action item.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Just also want to
add here that as of the 1st
of October 90% of Android
devices support
OpenGL version 2.
So anything remotely modern
will definitely do it.
But in terms of older devices
that don't support OpenGL
version 2, we're talking
about 9.2%.
So the majority of devices
definitely will support this.
It's not such a hard requirement
because you
definitely get better maps.
And the experience
on [INAUDIBLE]
wouldn't be worthwhile anyway.
So this isn't as strict a
requirement as it may seem.
TONY CHAN: OK.
Yeah.
Thanks, Ankur.
So that's pretty much all I have
for getting started to
have your apps to incorporate
the Maps.
And I'll pass it to Paul to
tell you guys more details
about all the features
in the new Maps API.
Paul.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
Yep, thanks, Tony.
So Tony took you through all the
steps to get prepped for
including a map.
And now I'll start off with
telling you actually how to
get the map in your
application from
code point of view.
So first thing is you definitely
want to set up a
layout to actually
hold the map.
And that layout component is a
fragment, or you can use a
fragment for that.
In the first example here we're
using the Support Map
Fragment because we're using
the Support Library.
But you can, if you're not using
the Support Library,
which you probably should be
using the Support Library,
just leave support out of the
Support Map Fragment line
there at the end.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So basically if
you're supporting devices
prior to Honeycomb, Android
3.0, you'll be using the
Support Library, because
we didn't have
Fragments prior to that.
Now given that Gingerbread,
which is 2.3, is still roughly
about 50% of the user base, you
almost definitely will be
using the Support Library.
So this is an important point.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep.
Yeah.
So we'll carry on under the
assumption that you're using
the Support Map Fragment.
But the code essentially
looks exactly the same.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Different
namespaces.
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly.
Different namespaces
and slightly
different function calls.
But yeah.
So when we're actually creating
our activity, using
the Support Library you define
it as a fragment activity.
Ankur, what is the fragment
activity?
Why isn't it not just
called fragment?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, in Android
3.0 and up where the
activities could host fragments,
now fragments are
part of the life
cycle as well.
Now prior to Android 3.0,
because there were no
fragments, those activities
don't support the fragment
life cycle.
So in the Support Library we
introduced a fragment activity
which extends activity.
But it adds the calls in for the
fragment life cycles, and
there you can host fragments.
That's why we're using the
fragment activity here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
And so from then on out it's
just a matter of getting the
map in your activity,
your fragment.
So it's called a Google
Map is the class name.
And you can see in the create
method is actually where
you're going to get it out of
your layout file just using
the ID that you specified
in your layout.
And I should mention the
activity main is the
activitymain.xml file for the
layout I defined up above.
So that's pretty much
it to get a map in
your activity or fragment.
So actually, with this code here
I'd have a map that was
basically the entire view.
But that fragment, obviously,
you can put anywhere in your
view hierarchy, so you could
embed it below some buttons or
in a modifiable pane,
that type of thing.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And now you can
actually have more than one.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So for all those
developers that have been
asking for Map fragments, we
want to see these apps that
use more than one
map at a time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Because I think
it'll be interesting to see
what kind of experience
you provide there.
Keep in mind that typically Maps
allow you to pan as well.
So if you've got swipe gestures
and so on, like if
you're using a ViewPager,
that introduces
an interesting dynamic.
Because the ViewPager itself can
swipe across pages, but if
you're hosting a map
it's going to
consume those swipe events.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, that's
an interesting point.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Just keep these sorts
of things in mind.
You can do tricks with
the ViewPager.
Because you can just press the
Tab at the top to go to the
next page, you can kind
of get away with it.
But if you've got a bunch of
pages where you're swiping
left or right to go through them
and suddenly there's a
map in there, it's going to
seem inconsistent to users
where they've been able
to swipe across pages.
Sometimes you've just got a
static map, in which case it
doesn't move, so you can
just allow the swipes.
But if it's consuming it, just
pay attention to the user
experience.
PAUL SAXMAN: All right.
Yeah.
And if you really want to see
multiple maps in an app at the
same time, definitely check out
the sample application,
the demo app that's part
of the SDK Tools.
I think there's one sample in
there that has four maps in a
single view.
And all the events are being
handled independently.
Pretty cool stuff.
So a couple of really
important things.
I'm just going to cover two kind
of high level concepts or
important Map concepts.
And these are the
basic use cases.
One is the camera.
So that's actually kind of your
viewport into the map or
what part of the map that you're
actually looking at.
And of the other is markers.
Markers are very fundamental
generally for most mapping
applications.
So camera and markers are what
we're going to cover today.
There's obviously a lot more
features to the API that we
can cover in a later show,
things like polylines and
polygons and ground overlays
and that type of thing.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I just have a
question for you, Paul.
For someone that doesn't
know, what would
you define as a marker?
What does that mean?
PAUL SAXMAN: We'll cover
that in just a second.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: I have
an image of that.
So a marker, just fundamentally
is if you want
to put a marker or a pin on the
map as to where somebody
or something is.
So the iconic marker that we
use for Google Maps is the
inverted teardrop.
It looks like an inverted
red teardrop.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So it's in a fixed
location, something that
sits on the map.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Well, not
necessarily fixed.
You can move them around
if you really want to.
And it's actually relatively
easy to move around.
But we'll cover a few of
these in a minutes.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Cool.
Sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: You'll see
what they look like.
So in terms of the camera, The
key concepts with camera is
obviously the camera location.
That's actually where the
camera is positioned
over top the map.
And that can actually
take two forms.
It's Lat/Long, so you can
actually center it at a
certain point on the map
or the view of the map.
And then the other
one is bounds.
And that takes two
Lat/Long objects.
So you can say I want the map
centered at this point, or I
want a certain area of
the map to be just
viewable in the display.
And you do that via
the bounds.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And so
it'll zoom out or
zoom in to cover those.
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly.
So let's say if you want to
actually show a neighborhood
and you know the top left and
bottom right coordinates for
that neighborhood, in terms
of geographic terms.
You just say I want to have this
bounds or this bounding
box, actually, displayed
on my map.
And the map will actually resume
and position itself to
actually display the entire
bounding area.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: So very useful if
you wanted to display area as
opposed to display a
particular point.
Displaying a particular point,
you just need the Lat/Long.
Zoom is actually essentially
how high the
camera is over the map.
So it's fairly fundamental, but
it's kind of analogous to
altitude, except that
it's inverted.
So 0 is actually zoomed
all the way out
and as you zoom in.
If you're at zoom 0, you
won't necessarily
get the entire map.
Zoom 0 just says that I'm going
to go as far out as the
viewport allows me to.
So if you have a very
big screen--
I haven't tried it on, let's
say, a Nexus 10, but
presumably if you're zoomed all
the way out on a Nexus 10
you'll actually see the entire
map of the world.
On a smaller device you'll
probably actually see a
fraction of the map.
I think you'll see the entire
map if it's like 256 dp.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I see.
PAUL SAXMAN: So bearing.
Now that we have vector-based
maps and you can actually
rotate them, which is a really
cool effect, bearing is
actually the rotation
of the map.
It actually rotates clockwise,
so bearing 0, north is at the
top of your interface.
And as you rotate the
bearing, actually,
the map rotates clockwise.
And you go all the way
up to 360, and then
you're back to north.
So 90 degrees, I think, is north
on the right-hand side
of the interface.
Tilt.
Again, this is a nice feature.
The nice feature of the
vector-based maps is actually
you can look at it
at an angle.
So you don't have to look at the
map exactly straight down.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Up, down.
PAUL SAXMAN: You can actually
specify a tilt.
0 is actually top down and
somewhere between like 45 and
90 degrees.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
It depends on your zoom level
as to how much tilt you can
have, right?
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly, exactly.
So if you're looking at a map at
45, you can definitely see
that there's an angle there.
If you actually bring it below
45, you start to see some kind
of 3D effect, so it will be a
little bit of kind of fogging
at the further end and
that type of thing.
So really great effect if you're
moving through the map
to have some kind of
tilt on the map.
Scrolling is actually just
programmatically moving the
position of the map.
And animation is a really
important topic too, because
when you're actually
repositioning the map you can
either do it instantaneously.
So let's say I want
to move from
New York to San Francisco.
I can have the map at one moment
display New York, and
then when I send the command
actually have
it display San Francisco.
Also you can actually have that
camera change animated.
So you can actually fly over the
United States to go from
New York to San Francisco.
Really nice effect for more
advanced use cases.
General use case, obviously
you'd reposition the map.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So I'll just add
that these capabilities of
zoom, rotation, bearing, tilt,
and scrolling, when you add
the map yourself, when you add
the map fragment, the typical
touch controls come with it.
So by default they're enabled.
So users can swipe
to pan around.
For those of you that don't
know, we have two-fingered
gestures for rotation where you
hold one finger steady and
rotate your other finger around
that steady finger.
Tilt is two fingers
up and down.
And well, scrolling
is scrolling.
There's also a trick
to zoom obviously.
There's pinching in your fingers
and pinching out.
But we've actually got a
one-handed gesture as well
where you can double tap it.
On a second tap you actually
hold it down and drag up and
down, and it zooms out.
So when you've got something
like a phone in your hand, you
can zoom on these maps
without having to put
these gestures in.
The reason it's important for
developers to know this is
that it comes for free with
the map fragment.
You don't need to implement
it yourself.
You can override it and disabled
if you want, though.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Actually, when we get to markers
I'll cover a few of
the events that you receive
on markers.
But yeah, you do actually get
a lot of these events.
You can override all of them,
but a lot of them are
available for override
as well.
But yeah, that double tap and
hold to zoom is definitely a
lifesaver a lot of times.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You're not using
it while you're driving or
anything, right, Paul?
PAUL SAXMAN: No, no.
Because these are vector
maps, you actually
can zoom to any level.
It's actually continuous zooming
scale, so unlike
tile-based or raster-based
mapping where you tend to do
it at discrete levels.
So having the ability to
actually just slide and zoom
is really nice from a
user's perspective.
The last thing that we'll
talk about a little bit,
positioning versus updating
of the camera.
Just lost the lights in here.
There we go.
So positioning is actually
moving the camera.
And actually you specify
between location, zoom,
bearing, and tilt whichever ones
you want to specify of
those four.
And you change the
camera position.
All the other ones are
actually defaulted.
So if I, say, move to New York
and I just pass the Lat/Longs
to New York, it'll go to default
zoom level, default
bearing, tilt, et cetera.
And positioning is kind of the
default way to actually move
the view around the map.
On the other hand, camera
updating is you're just
changing a particular
attribute,
so for example location.
So this is where scrolling comes
is if I want to scroll
the viewport left to right or I
want to actually zoom in one
level or zoom out one level,
these are just updates.
I'm not actually changing the
entire camera position.
So position is for actually
starting from scratch and
changing the viewport or
where the camera's
position over the map.
And updating is actually just
incrementally changing.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And updating
also animates to the
destination, right?
PAUL SAXMAN: You can or can't.
So animation is something
that you
essentially turn on or off.
So I'll show a little bit I
think on the next slide where
we have a little bit of code.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
Actually I left the animation
out of this one, but I think I
have it in a later slide.
So in terms of camera position,
bearing and tile are
actually only available
in position.
So bearing and tile aren't
available in updates.
I'm not exactly sure
why we didn't
include them in updates.
Probably because of the
primary use cases of
positioning.
But you can see here there in
this camera position builder.
This is more or less
a factory object.
I can actually specify
the target, zoom,
bearing, and tilt.
Zoom, bearing, and tilt
are all optional.
So if you just want to
reposition, like I said, at
default zoom, bearing, and tilt
levels, you just specify
the target, and the map will
kind of start over again at
that location.
The zoom, bearing, and tilt you
can optionally set to get
a particular effect.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I'm a bit of a
fan of the fact that these
methods all return the same
object back so that you can
change them in this nice way--
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: --without having
a ton of verbose code that
states your same object
over and over again.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
The really nice feature in this
builder is that you just
kind of build these things
up and fire them away.
So once you have this new camera
position, you just pass
it to the camera update factory,
get your camera
update object out, and then you
just do map.movecamera.
And the other one, what
is it called?
I'm going to go to the--
I just cheated right there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Nobody
saw it, though.
It's not like this is recorded
or anything.
PAUL SAXMAN: No,
of course not.
Nobody will notice that
10-frame slide
switch that I just did.
So yeah, so map.movecamera,
you just pass the camera
update map.animate.
Oh, jeez, I forgot already.
Animate camera will actually
animate the transition.
So once you have this camera
update object, you can make a
decision about how you want
to do the transition.
So camera update, on
the other hand, is
a little bit different.
So we're going directly to that
cut camera update class,
so we're not actually using
the camera position class.
So here we have a camera
update factory.
I can specify the Lat/Long.
Like I said before--
and that's for the center
of the map--
I can also do a Lat/Long zoom
here where I specify a new
Lat/Long and zoom level.
And that can also do the
bounds here as well.
So if I want to basically zoom
out to show a neighborhood or
zoom in to show a particular
area of the city, these are
very convenient functions
for doing that.
So scrolling is actually
part of the camera
update class as well.
So scrolling and zoom, the
primary use cases I see for
these two, as opposed to using
camera position, is for if you
want to actually do your
own map controls.
Let's say you want to provide
your own zoom buttons or you
want to actually provide your
own panning buttons.
There are really a next
class to use.
Another use case is let's
say you're animating a
sprite on the map.
Let's say he's walking across
the map to show directions to
the grocery store.
You can actually use the
scrolling method to actually
scroll the change.
And again, these are actually
animated or not animated.
Interesting thing about zoom
is you can actually do zoom
in, zoom out, zoom by a certain
percentage, or zoom to
one of the discrete levels.
Markers, we'll talk about
these real quick.
Positioning markers is obviously
very important
because markers actually
show a particular
geolocation on the map.
Info windows, this is
information that's related to
a position or a marker
that you can display.
Dragging is actually you can
allow users to move the marker
around the map if
they want to.
This is a little bit of an
advanced thing, but is
actually really easy to do.
Icons.
So there's obviously a default
marker icon, which, as I said
before, is the inverted
teardrop.
But you can actually
customize it.
Actually I have this
a little bit wrong.
So customizing is actually
part of Info Windows that
we'll talk about later.
But icons you can actually
customize by specifying unique
colors, specifying your images
or bitmaps and specifying how
they anchor on that.
And then there's events
on markers as well.
So in terms of positioning Info
Windows and dragging,
really easy to do.
This is a huge update from
the Map View 1.0.
Position basically you add
a marker to your map, you
specify your marker options,
and then you set whatever
properties you want.
Position is you absolutely
have to have a position.
If you don't have a position for
your marker and you try to
place it on the map, you're
going to get an exception.
Title, snippet, and dragable
are all optional.
So if you specify title and/or
snippet, actually you'll get
an Info Window.
So on the right-hand side, the
red inverted teardrop is
actually the marker just to show
where the position is,
the Lat/Long coordinates are.
And the title and the snippets
show up in the Info Window.
So by default Info
Windows are off.
You can actually turn them on.
I think it's actually
marker.showinfowindow.
That will actually
programmatically display the
Info Window.
And there's also, I believe, a
hide method as well, so if you
want to programmatically
hide it.
So by default they're off.
By default if you specify title
or snippet and the user
touches the marker you'll
see the Info Window.
Dragable is a neat thing.
You have to see it
to understand
exactly what it does.
But the default behavior is that
if a user long presses a
marker and the marker is
dragable, which is specified
with this dragable true, the
marker actually becomes
repositionable by the user.
So this is really great use case
if you want to actually
get feedback from
the user about
the location of something.
So in terms of the icons or
the images, all this is
actually accessed through these
marker options, or you
specify marker images or colors
images and anchoring
via the marker options class.
So as I said before, position
has to be in all of these, so
all of these actually
show position here.
So the first thing is that you
can pretty easily change the
color using this bitmap
descriptor factory.
And you actually just
specify the hue.
You can specify use one of
our pre-canned hues.
I can't remember exactly how
many of them there are, but
there's a fair number of pretty
appealing colors.
Or you can actually specify
the hue using a float.
You can specify your
own image.
The easiest way to get the image
in there is having it in
your APK and just specify the
resource to load the bitmap.
I think there's a number
of other ways.
You can actually pass a bitmap
object if you want, so you
could actually generate a marker
image on the fly if you
really wanted to.
I think the other options it's
like a resource identifier.
You can specify a
bitmap object.
You can specify a file if you
want to actually load the file
out of storage.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Typically for the file situation
you might want to
download it from the
web or something.
But yeah, as much as possible
you want to use resource IDs
because you can chuck them in
your drawable directories and
get the right scale to image for
whatever DPI the device is
running at that time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Really the primary use case I
see for using a file or a
bitmap for that matter is
actually if you're doing
something like overlaying
images, for
example, on your map.
So there you're specifying,
let's say, this image is
associated with this position
on the map.
So you could actually just load
that from local storage
or over the wire--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: --as opposed
to out of
your resources directory.
But if you're just reusing the
same icon over and over again,
definitely drop it in your
resources directory.
So I'm just going to go back to
the last slide real quick.
So the anchor on the default
marker is actually the very
bottom center of that
red teardrop.
So that's actually where the
coordinates are when I specify--
Well, in this case it shows 0,
0, but that's definitely not
San Francisco Lat/Long.
So the Lat/Long is actually
associated with the bottom
center of that teardrop,
which is the pinpoint.
So you can actually change
that, however.
So what I had done before
I wish I could show you.
But you can create your own
custom marker icon.
And you can do things like
put a drop shadow on it.
Or you could offset the pinpoint
off a little bit to
the left or right so you can
just customize it to make it
look a little more appealing
to your application.
If you do that you have to set a
new anchor point, and that's
the very last method down in
the anchoring section, so
that's percentage
from top left.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Would a good use
case for this be something
like where your marker
is like a pin?
It's kind of angled, and so the
center point of the marker
isn't actually the point that
touches the ground.
And so if you set the position
to be that marker, it would
have put the center point rather
in the bottom right
corner, if it was a
pin, for example.
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly.
I think the classic marker
is actually the pin.
And generally it's positioned
so the pinpoint is at the
bottom left of the image.
Yeah.
So in that case you actually
have to specify an anchor.
And the anchor would be 0, 1,
because you're 0% along the
x-axis and 100% along the
y-axis, because the origin is
the top left of the image.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes.
PAUL SAXMAN: So for the default
marker it's going to
be 0.51 because it's
the center bottom.
And for the case where you have
the push pin, it's going
to be 0, 1.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Got you.
PAUL SAXMAN: So just base
and percentage points.
I definitely should've covered
map events, but maybe we can
talk about those
in another one.
Marker events are actually
really important because it's
the way that users actually
interact with your pinpoints
for your markers on your map.
So by default our users can
actually touch the icons.
If you have an Info Window, the
default behavior is the
Info Window is displayed and
users can actually touch the
Info Window.
So this would be use cases let's
say you don't want to
show all the restaurants
in a particular city.
You can put markers on the map
for all the restaurants.
The user can press the marker
to actually see the Info
Window, which would be, let's
say, the restaurant name.
And if the user touches the
Info Window, that can take
them to a details page.
So that's the rationale behind
things like the on-marker
click listener, because you know
when the user clicked the
marker, the on-window click
listener, because you know
when the user actually clicked
the Info Window, and then
marker drag, because like we
showed before users can
actually move the market
around the map.
There's also a marker drag
listener as well.
So the way that you actually
set yourself up to receive
these events is you define the
listeners, any one of those
three or all three
if you want.
You register your listeners.
Once you've actually created
your map, you can actually
specify who your
listeners are.
The easiest case is if you
attach the listeners to your
activity and then when you
create the map just pass in a
reference to your activity.
And then once that's all set
up, you implement these
methods in your activity or
fragment, and you can start
receiving these events
and do fun and
interesting stuff with them.
So drag, drag in, and drag start
are obviously associated
with the marker drag listener.
Info Window click listener and
on-marker click is the
on-marker click listener.
And for each of these you
obviously, as you can see, you
get the marker that was touched,
click, dragged, or
whatever else.
So I think that's it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Thanks for that.
Just so that you all know, today
was part one in a series
of ADL+ shows that we're going
to have about the Maps API.
The next episode won't
be this year.
It'll be early next year.
But we're going to go into some
more of what we consider
our more advanced topics, like
polylines line and so on.
But we've got some really cool
stuff coming up around in and
around the API.
So with that being said,
let us move onto Q&A.
TONY CHAN: Ankur, we got a
couple questions from Lindon
on the chat window.
So maybe we can take
a look at them.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Awesome.
Welcome, Lindon.
And Andrew was on there
for a while as well.
OK.
There's quite a lot of chatter
here, so I'm just trying to
see where the first question--
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
Let me read the first question
to you guys.
So the first question was, "Any
chance we can access the
frame buffer for Google Maps
to wrap a big map?
Well, it was possible with
MapView version 1 and, of
course, the [INAUDIBLE]
I had just [INAUDIBLE]
with the old API." So that's
the first question.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I don't believe
it's possible
right now to do it.
This API does not allow you
to grab the frame buffer.
But it's something that I can
take back to the team.
Just out of interest, Lindon,
if you're still on, what are
your use cases?
It'll just help us explain
it better to
the engineering team.
I think Lindon's a
bit shy today.
He's got his--
"Sharing an image." So it's an
image that you're actually
taking off your app,
like a screenshot?
"Close
to it." OK.
Look, it's not there
right now.
Let me talk it over
with the team.
There may be reason that
we didn't do that.
And we'll get back to you.
PAUL SAXMAN: One potential
alternative, if you just want
a snapshot of the map, is
there is the Google Maps
static image API.
[INAUDIBLE] also
doesn't do it.
So yeah, you should essentially
get the exact same
information back if you specify
the bounding box for
what you want to get from
the static images API.
So yeah, static maps is--
ANKUR KOTWAL: [INAUDIBLE]
work on.
Yeah.
So for now you'll
have to do that.
But obviously that wouldn't
cater for us if you've got
custom markers--
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly, yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: --and
things like that.
So if you're doing very
Android-centric things--
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
And generally direct tile access
is what we call it or
actually extracting the map
information out, we
generally shun that.
It actually violates their
terms, which is why we have
things like the static
map API.
But yeah, I think it's
definitely worth talking with
the engineering team to see what
kind of use cases we can
support around this.
Because definitely it is nice
to share your RAMs.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
OK.
Next question.
Tony, you want to just
read them out for us?
TONY CHAN: Yeah, sure.
The next question, "Is it
possible to overlay another
OpenGL view that has transparent
background on top
of Google Maps?
Is that what Ingress
is doing?"
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, I
think Ingress is
doing something special.
Yeah, so we can't talk about
what Ingress is doing.
But I think Ingress is doing
something special.
As to whether you can do that
with this library, my gut
feeling is no, because I believe
we render directly to
the surface.
And there will be some
complications around that.
So I'm pretty sure the
answer is no, Lindon.
TONY CHAN: Lindon said
we were enlightened.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Actually,
I'm not.
I'm on the resistance side.
OK.
Were there any other questions
from Lindon?
In the meanwhile, whilst he asks
those questions I'll just
bring up some questions that
Andrew asked before he left.
This is on the Moderator page.
"I haven't had a chance to look
at the new v2 maps, and
I've been meaning to." Just
waiting for a refresh.
That was a bad time
to hit Refresh.
PAUL SAXMAN: There we go.
ANKUR KOTWAL: "Does this mean I
don't have to use the Users
Library tag anymore?
Does this is also mean I don't
need to use the Google API's
checkbox in the Eclipse plug-in
to support Google
Maps?" So Users Library,
we no longer need that?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So the process now is
that you use the
library project in Android.
And that's the Google Play
Services library project.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yep.
For the checkbox, however,
for the Google APIs--
So when he says Eclipse plug-in,
I think what he's
talking about is the AVD
manager, the Android Virtual
Device manager.
You definitely do need to use
the Google API's image,
because this is part
of Google.
Well, the Maps API is part of
Google Play services, which
does rely on the Google
API access.
So that hasn't changed.
OK.
That's all the questions
on Moderator.
If anyone has any more
questions, now's
the time to ask them.
Whilst we wait for that to
happen, as I said, we'll be
taking a couple of weeks
off for ADL+.
But our first episode back will
be focusing around some
more of the capabilities
of this API.
And then in a future episode
we'll be talking about some
really cool recipes that you
could do with the API.
And we've got some sample
apps to show off.
Yes.
Coming soon.
Well, I don't think there's
anything more.
So thank you very much
for joining us.
PAUL SAXMAN: My pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
I love to talk about
this stuff.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
We'll definitely try to have
you on more often.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
My pleasure.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thanks, Tony, for
joining as well and Lindon
as well and Andrew for
your question.
And we will catch you next
time or next year.
Hope you all have a great
and safe holiday
and a happy New Year.
TONY CHAN: Happy holidays.